foreign
field what's up Bros
hello hello
how are you incredible how are you
I'm good good what's up what are you
doing
uh well uh just waiting around for you
to pick up my phone call that's what all
right well I got you what's happening
let's do this
Beyonce
um
uh I've I've come to realize over the
course of our relationship that I think
he's on the Spectrum
and I I don't know how to tell them
because I know if I tell them um it's
going to be an insult to him he's he was
he's been insulted his whole life he had
like a really hard childhood every mean
thing any adult figure could have ever
said to him they said it
um you know verbally physically abused
like
um
uh and and so to you know so I
understand to like bring that up
shouldn't be an insult to someone but it
might be to him just considering he's
been degraded so much for through his
whole life and I'm just sensitive to
that and and then the other thing is is
that now that I've become aware or I've
come to believe that he's on the
Spectrum
so many of our arguments kind of make
more sense in hindsight
[Music]
and I'm trying to learn how to like
support him or like air quotes argue or
communicate properly and I don't know
where to start and I don't know where to
get him resources and I don't know where
to get resources for myself and so then
that's why I'm calling you I appreciate
that
um
okay
so two things well let me ask you
permission can I be super honest and
straight and direct with you is that
cool
okay awesome
um
I guess one one day Rose someone's gonna
tell me
um no I prefer you just tell me exactly
what I would like to hear and nobody's
done that yet so okay
first thing here
I would with all of my heart all my guts
all my strength in mind would tell you
don't be in the business of pseudo
diagnosing people that you love and care
about
right I would whatever
I imagine you are reaching for somebody
you love how can I love you better so
it's not like I'm not trying to beat you
up over it what I'm telling you is
um as the great brene Brown says what we
go looking for in the world we are sure
to find
and when we put Diagnostics glasses on
and we begin looking through the world
we will see them everywhere I could give
you a
um series of uh
uh behaviors
that would suggest he has depressive
disorder
and if you put those glasses on you
would see it everywhere and I could give
you another series of behaviors and
responses and reactivities uh with
anxiety disorder and you would see it
everywhere so I always want to be
careful about putting those glasses on
okay
um
the second thing I want you to really be
careful of as you're heading into this
marriage and we'll get to the autism
conversation here but it all works it's
all synergistic here
you cannot build a marriage on trying to
hedge truth in conversations
the goal can't be how do I tell how do I
do a thing how do I respond a thing do I
a thing I think my husband has but I
don't want to tell him he's got it I
just want to start doing these things
because that's always going to fall down
at some point
so the goal the goal is how do we come
to an understanding together that the
way we are communicating with one
another the way we are experiencing each
other is not working and one of the
things might be because my husband has
perception challenges or feels
exceptionally it feels powerfully about
things right
um so uh or is it lacks a little bit of
empathy or is oh so over empathetic it
shuts his body down right so
you see the difference there
um well yeah I I do know that you know
uh we can't we need to be honest but at
the same time like I know that we're not
supposed to
uh like you said pseudo diagnose and and
that's where I'm just kind of lost and I
don't know what to do so if I'm in your
seat if I'm in your exact seat the
conversation I would have
verbatim would be
I love you so much
and I want some tools so that I can do a
better job of communicating with you
I'm not doing a good job of telling you
my needs in a way that you can hear them
and understand them
and I'm not doing a good job of hearing
and responding to your needs
would you be willing to go see a
premarital counselor with me and in this
situation not some
buddy who's like done a bunch of
weddings and they make you go through
three things in a workbook but I'm
talking about a true marriage counselor
who also by the way has the licensure
the ability and the experience to do
diagnostics
and once you lay out a series of here's
how were some of our communication
challenges are happening
every Bell in that therapist office
should go off if it's a true autistic
diagnostic
okay does that make sense yeah no that
sounds like a good um pass forward and I
know he'll
um and he probably feels it deeply right
oh yeah yeah because we've we've talked
about
like our miscommunications like um
we know there's a disconnect
um yeah he knows that there's a
disconnect some you know at times we are
getting better at communicating and
realizing
you know the the difference is
um
but you know he is a Christian and I do
believe that he would love to do
premarital counseling so so oh and
I've got tons of friends who are pastors
I want to steer you away from just doing
traditional pastoral
um oh no yes I want
I want to see someone who can diagnose
there you go that's right and so and and
here's where so on one hand I was just
telling you I don't like Diagnostics
like just as a blanket but there's some
great utility they serve a good purpose
and here's a great a great place
right now I can imagine
when the lights are low
your fiance thinks he's doing something
wrong he's screwing something up
he thinks that all the all the time all
the time he thinks he's one giant big
screw-up like all the time yes and he's
got so much he's got trauma in his
background he's got abuse and all the
stuff going on in his past
and a diagnosis would be able to say hey
your brain and body simply interacts
with the world in a different way
and so since it does great
you are not accumulation you are not
seven feet tall with a great fade away
you are Steph Curry
you're I don't know five eight you're
gonna have to to be successful in
basketball you just have to do different
things you're gonna have to learn to
shoot the ball from really far away cool
you're not taking you off the field
we're just gonna tell you hey you're not
ever going to be a good post player
because you're you're 5'10 or whatever
tall Steph Curry is it's a very similar
situation here I remember some peace
when I was told
hey if we were going to do diagnostics
here here's what you would have
and I'd be like ah okay
it gives me a place to start from
it's not an ex it's not an excuse it's
just a context right so I think it could
be helpful or for you it could be
helpful to find out no he's not autistic
he's not
um
but do you love him yes cool then we're
going to figure out how to communicate
together and there is
I I have no qualms at all about marrying
somebody on the Spectrum none zero
yeah I mean I I initially couldn't tell
um I did have a friend who told me like
right off the bat but I didn't believe
her I was like no no he doesn't but
um I guess she had more experience in
that world than I do so she saw it
faster and it took me
longer to like clue in
um I used to work with actually severely
autistic children in preschool
um but he's very high functioning um he
actually has a doctorate in chemistry
um so it just took me
longer to figure it out in him if he is
truly autistic it may have been a
superpower in his chosen profession
and similarly
boxers with who are just innate they're
born with great hand speed it is
incredible for their job but they have
to learn a different way to interact at
home
and that's what we're talking about here
even if some of it's going through the
motions
right maybe he will never be able to
walk home and feel how you are how your
day went
but he can learn the six questions that
he's going to ask when he walks in the
front door all six of them pertaining to
you and how are you
and you're gonna learn maybe it's not
that he's not empathetic maybe your
feelings are so intense they burn his
skin like it just burns a hole through
him like fire and that's why he
stare straight ahead and so you might
have to learn how to regulate see you
see what I'm saying it's just going to
be a dance that y'all are going to have
to have to learn but dancing is so fun
if you have the right Spirit about it
right
right yeah cool so I would I would I
would hold off on saying the the man
that I love is a is this fill in the
blank diagnosis I would be all about hey
let's learn some new skills let's go see
a professional let's go sit down and
figure this stuff out together the focus
y'all are gonna have is communication
telling the truth learning how to see
and
um depending on where he falls on the
Spectrum with intuition
um and then learning about like some
things aren't about routines and some
things aren't uh you can't logic your
way through grief you can't logic your
way through pain and hurt and all that
kind of stuff
um sometimes you have to sit in and you
have to feel and so it's just going to
be people learning new skills people
people learning new skills I've got no
doubt y'all can make this happen let the
professional do the diagnosing let the
professional put that on the table you
just show up and say I want to be the
best supporter and best friend and best
wife I can be
and hope your husband shows up too thank
you so much for the call we'll be right
yes before we go to break I'd like to
point out Steph Curry is six two he's
how tall six two it's not like he's you
know he thought it was like five six
he's six two so that's how tall I am
good grief well there I go on that one
yeah just when you see him against with
his teammates well when he said next to
someone that's seven foot tall
but he's 6'2 he's not short by any
stress well Steph Curry is a huge fan of
the show stuff I'm sorry I'm sorry
that uh
I made you feel small
you're 60. we're the same height I
challenge you to a basketball game
anytime you're up for it bring it